this is the first season of Game of
Thrones we have learned that Petyr
Baelish is a cunning unpredictable and
ruthless manipulator of court politics
as very subservience elf little fingers
a grasper from a minor house with a
great skillet befriending and eventually
maneuvering powerful people his
treatment by the tallies when he was a
young man and his near death at the hand
of Brandon Stark and buried him against
both the tallies and the Starks
Littlefinger orchestrated the entire
world five kings of war in which tens of
thousands of soldiers and civilians have
died Littlefinger's we can call Ginny's
plan back in season one was to kill Jon
Arryn with the help of John's song wife
which he did and then to make Ned Stark
as the new hand of the king whereupon he
helped Ned to figure out who Joffrey's
real father is Littlefinger knew that it
would lead Honorable Ned to reveal the
truth to everyone else which led to King
Robert Baratheon's death as well as to
Ned Stark's beheading which started the
war of the five kings
long story short little finger through
the Seven Kingdoms into the state of
chaos from which he personally benefited
let me highlight one Maris's quote
regarding little finger
Littlefinger was born with no lands no
wealth no armies he has acquired the
first to have long before he has the
army
perhaps you laugh but I know him better
than most and this is the truth
well finger is one of the most dangerous
men in Westeros and let me also say that
this conversation between Varys and
Elena took place in the fourth episode
of the third season mean my little
finger married Liza Tully widow of Lord
Jon Arryn of the Vale who poisoned Jon
on Littlefinger's order and therefore
Petyr Baelish became the Lord Protector
of the Vale
however as very said Littlefinger became
very powerful man with Lance and wealth
and recently he also managed to provide
himself an army that he is basically
commanding with which he provided by
being able to heavily influence the
young Lord Robin the new lord paramount
of the Vale Petyr Baelish also did all
he could to set sense as a queen in the
north he betrayed Ned Stark in order to
set up a fight between wolves and lions
poison Joffrey and Joffrey's on wedding
to save Sansa and then handing her over
to Bolton's all in order to turn the
north against Bolton sent to give him an
opportunity to lead the Knights of the
Vale that he is commanding way
by manipulating young Lord Robin which
he provided by killing Robbie's father
and mother all in order to set sense as
the Queen in the north convinced that it
will lead to marriage between him and
the new queen of the north which would
provide him northern army as we saw in
season six finale in the barrels
aftermath Littlefinger approach sensing
the godswood and admitted that his goal
is to sit on the Iron Throne with her by
his side with her as his queen
however despite him being arguably the
most cunning and the most intelligent
player in the game Baelish is not
incapable of making mistakes
Littlefinger did not expect sensibly
refused to be a part of his plan to be
his queen as she refused to trust him
due to his tendency to betray those he
declares for Littlefinger second mistake
is believing that the northern Lords
would rally behind Sansa Stark which
would have made her the queen in the
north rather than behind ax as he said
himself motherless bastard born in the
south as we saw by his face expression
in season six finale Littlefinger did
not expect the John who is not even a
near House Stark would be proclaimed as
the King in the north by other northern
Lords and as we saw on his face
expression that's also the moment in
which he started making a new plan his
new plan involves senses his wife which
he will try to accomplish by either
manipulation or threats as a wife with
whom he would manipulate as he is
manipulating with Robin which would
provide him the northern army and would
lead him one step further to conquering
the Iron Throne he is planned by these
theories to either make a conflict
between Jon Snow in the north or to
arrange John's death but also to make
sure that this time he gets the northern
army which Mehring sense I would assure
the same plan will according to my
theory and with Littlefinger's death an
event that is going to be orchestrated
by the stark sisters
however today I'm not going to talk
about this theory as I already brought
you a video regarding that topic by the
name the white wedding which you can
check out in my previous videos if you
would like to hear more details where
all of this being said let's see if
there is any evidence that Petyr Baelish
beside orchestrating a major civil war
in Seven Kingdoms known as the world the
five kings all sorc is traded the great
civil war among the Great Houses so
Westeros known as the War of the usurper
or more popularly Robert's rebellion as
well known Robert's
result of the collapse of the Targaryen
dynasty and the intention of Robert
Baratheon to the Iron Throne I know that
most of you are probably confused at
this point and are probably wondering
why would heaven how could have he
orchestrated Robert's rebellion well
it's actually pretty simple and there
are two reasons revenge and benefit well
in the following minutes he will be
introduced with how exactly he might
have done it
Peter's father served well under Lord
hoster Tully and through their good
relationship hoster agreed to foster his
son Peter at Riverrun which was a great
honor for house Baelish Peter went river
on when he was 8 years old and there he
befriended hosters daughter Kathleen and
Lysa Tully while their brother Ed Muir
mockingly nicknamed him Littlefinger the
nickname that would stick with him
throughout his life Peter became
obsessive with Catelyn but she never
returned his affections eventually man
she was engaged to Brandon Stark net's
older brother heir to Lord of Winterfell
and Lord paramount of the north
Peter challenged him to a duel Brandon
defeated Baelish easily nearly
disembowelling him in the process but
Catelyn back Brandon to spare his life
the Masters were able to say Baelish and
he eventually recovered but he was left
with a deep scar running from his
stomach to his collarbone a token from
Brandon that Baelish would carry with
him whereupon Baelish was cast out of
Riverrun and returned to Vale later
Brandon Stark who had been on his way to
Riverrun to Wed Catelyn Tully was
enraged you - most likely false rumors
about Prince Rhaegar Targaryen
subduction over his sister Lyanna and
instead Riverrun he rode to King's
Landing immediately to demand Rhaegar's
arrest and punishment ere is the Mad
King arrested Brandon for treason and
eventually killed him and his father
record on a horrific and unjust way
which led to house Baratheon stark and
Aaron rebelling against the Iron Throne
now in my opinion those false rumors
about Reger's abduction over Liana that
basically started Robert's rebellion
were rumoured by none other than Petyr
Baelish himself
well I'm sure most of us would agree the
trogir in leon allowed each other rather
than honorable ragaar kidnapped and
raped Liana
it's still unknown why they decided to
leave without a word
but with all evidence about how kind and
Noble
and Lia number it's also hard to believe
that they would have lettuce seven
kingdoms as well as their own families
burned for their love on the one hand we
have Brandon who at the time had been on
his way to Riverrun to vet Catelyn Tully
while on the other hand we have Liana
who was in the Riverlands and at the
same time allegedly kidnapped by Rhaegar
I don't know if it's only me and my or
thinking but to me that's impossible
that Littlefinger spread the false
rumors in order to prevent a wedding
between his beloved Catelyn and Brandon
Stark as well as to seek revenge against
Brandon who almost killed him some time
earlier now before I go any further let
me just show you one clip from the third
episode of the very first season that is
going in favour to this theory one of
several such establishments I own a very
funny man
stocks as you can see a third was
furious velu finger brought him to a
brothel believing that he is the victim
of a bad joke but cathlin intervened
when Ned attacked Littlefinger where
poor little finger said the Starks quick
tempers slow minds could it be that
Littlefinger spread false rumors about
Reger's abduction over Lyanna stark
knowing that it would lead Brandon Stark
who's also known as the wild wolf to do
something honorable and stupid at the
same time which were the result with
Brandon not continuing his travel to
Riverrun to Wed Catelyn but instead to
ride to King's Landing and eventually
die which is exactly what happened
could it be that this Littlefinger's
quote about the Starks was actually
foreshadow of Ned Stark's death because
just as Brandon Ned Stark had a quick
temper but didn't figure out little
fingers manipulation in the seventh
episode of the first season Littlefinger
said that there's one thing he learned
from losing his duel to Brandon Stark he
learned that he will never be known
their honorable way but will rather as
he set himself manipulate them to
provide himself everything he wants
which at first was Catelyn Tully and
revenge against Brandon Stark
in conclusion there's a high possibility
that Liu finger did spread false rumors
about Reger's kidnap over Liana in order
to prevent Brandon Starks marriage with
his beloved Catelyn since he knew
Brandon had a quick temper which instead
of thinking twice about his next act
resulted with him riding to King's
Landing immediately and demanding
justice from the Mad King which resulted
just as Littlefinger wanted with
Brandon's death there's one more fact
that is going favored to this theory
which is a high possibility of Petyr
Baelish knowing that Rhaegar did not
abduct and rape Liana which fourth
episode of the fifth season almost
certainly confirmed there's a scene in
which Peter finds sense and crypts of
Winterfell Pankhurst back to her
deceased family members
Peter recalls about how Rhaegar
Targaryen shows senses aunt Lyanna
which started Robert's rebellion against
the Targaryen family on which sense are
replied with confirming that dragger did
choose her aunt along with the statement
that he also kidnapped her and raped her
on which Littlefinger didn't reply
I but he didn't even have to his face
expression was more than enough now this
same beside being a clue back in the
fifth season that Jon Snow is not Ned
Stark's bastard but rather son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark also
seems to be another clue that this
theory that I've introduced you with
today might come true since it seems
Littlefinger knows the truth while I'm
convinced that Littlefinger did spread
the false rumors about Wreckers
abduction over Liana there are most
certainly a few more mysteries about the
relationship between Rhaegar and Lyanna
and I'm sure most of them will be
revealed in the upcoming season through
brands vision I'm looking forward to
finding out why Liana did not leave a
simple note for her family that could
have prevented death of her father and
brother as well as the deaths of
thousands of soldiers and innocent
people that died during Robert's
rebellion while there's also possibility
that Liana wrote a note but it simply
was handed over to a wrong person and
was never read by the Starks hopefully
the seventh season will provide an
answer on all those questions and
mysteries